just testing is not complicated right
but you just have to be careful because
we are at a point in the course where
you know all what a maths right any kind
of math you already know about that can
be construed in an athletic way can be
brought in and you need to think back to
your mother
so this let's do the first one
accessibility I we do the first pin and
you get a difference you do the second
pair and you find that the difference is
four which is not the same okay so all
you need to stick this is not a pain is
to state that these are not equal right
so this line is by logic line this line
is mine it doesn't fit the condition I
want it right so I was aiming for please
answer the question the question doesn't
say go through a bunch of equations the
question says test so do you say yes or
no right so give me an answer at the end
conclusions will become even more
important one good right next topic in
calculus but he also important now you
have a look at this guy the skeleton of
the proof is exactly the same skeleton
the methods another thing we're gonna do
a pair a pair and then show or not show
equivalence right but of course because
here you have logs
you need to recall that you shouldn't
just pack up and go home after riding
that right your Lord must tell you what
can you do how do those two interact
it's a show quicker than with which it's
a test so there we have to show what can
I do with this log base 3 all now the
reason why it's - the reason why is - is
because when you combine logs in this
way when you subtract you divide these
two terms in your right so I'm going to
put in that 1005 to show I knew what's
going on run I just tucked into my
calculator I lived in picnics me it's
always that and that's where log base 3
of 2 comes from and I'm going to
rehearse that for the next step now keep
in mind I have no idea what log base 3
of 2 years I mean I assume it's
something like one's a half aa dinner
okay one point something like that but I
don't need to know what's value is to
know the two values are the same okay I
can still get the same result
Hyup okay and so therefore I have this
the rest of them I'm sure they are
wasn't there for it easily
oh sure yeah yeah you if you if you want
to actually calculate it that's still
fine it's rather a longer way to do it
but you're still get this result what
you like as in you still get these
equivalents okay
does any other questions about the
testes okay the testing like I said
often times at the firm you use one of
these properties you have to sell yeah
it's and they paid before you can say
any ap stuff without it now question
four I know some of you have started it
again
the be clued I mean wearing up we're in
a lesson to that ApS right
the positive multiples of 11 this is a
sequence right and it the particular
time sequence is it's an AP with first
term 0 11 first well positive first term
11 and common difference 11 right so
therefore now that I don't and ER I can
immediately write what the formula for
every term is okay
now when you have a look at this I'm
going to say to you then first 10 plus n
minus 1 months of the common difference
okay but it becomes pretty obvious right
you've got it 11 here and then you've
got a takeaway 11 they're like we're
just gonna cancel that you're just like
oh yeah actually that's not that
surprising okay but what do I do with
this is the question okay where am i how
am I gonna use this right well what I
want is I know there's some number of
terms that are between 500 and 2,000 let
me say that again
they are solvent terms there are some
terms that are between between 500
and mm and you have to write this
straight no of course not but this will
probably be the quickest way the most
direct statement to get to between
500,000 now being that I know exactly
what um you mean this yeah I'm kind of
once I've stated it like just like these
things I can kind of assume dog okay but
obviously will come into play in a
second when I get some fractions out of
this now before I go ahead and solve
what does your intuition tell you about
how many answers roughly you're
expecting okay now 2,000 take away 500
is 1,500 right now divided by 11 is
awkward but a number that's close to
that which I can easily divide by is 10
now how many multiples of 10 are there
in 1500 about 150 right now this is
multiples of 11 they come up just a
little less frequently so I'm gonna put
me expect a bit under 150 that's what
Mike intuition is telling me and when I
get an answer at the end I'll see if I'm
on the right track so I'm just going to
divide by 11 right what am I gonna get
we're gonna get some mixed name was
again right
sounds like recurring for level 5 I know
but I want a fraction just because I'm
lazy right dogs it sounds like for 11s
right finally 5 11 is right 7i rigid
yeah it's five okay and then the other
one I'm gonna get 181 and if I have my
numbers right 911 is that right okay now
again what's great about this is that to
answer this question you constantly
machine a formula you have to take this
result that we got from the formula and
interpret it okay so how do I get from
this to an answer right think about for
a second yeah how many terms in my
sequence my
even I'm interested how many turns are
under 500 look at the inequalities how
many terms there are 45 turns 45 terms
with no bits right less than how many
choice are less than 2000 180 181 right
because we haven't heard any second term
will not meet this condition you'll be
over 2,000 right 181 no let me explain
why after this why is it that there are
45 terms less because if I think about
this right the first term on this side
to break this inequality the first term
is term 45 right term 46 is inside turn
45 outside right so turn 45 is outside
44 is outside and 43 and 42 all the way
down to one right so all the way over
here I have term one here all the way up
until term 45 which of course is 45
times and then the next one will be
inside my nice region alright so if I
have this many lessons in 2000 but I
need to take away these ones because
they're not more than 500 then it's
gonna be 180 one takeaway 45 which i
think is 136 which matches our intuition
of something less than 150 we're in the
rival Bob